when i was in high school well okay when
i was nine i got molested by a guy with
down syndrome
don't laugh right now i'm not laughing
why'd you laugh i'm it's just
that's [ __ ] rude it's such a
curveball i know can i just say
something
i'm going to say it again and if you
smile i'm going to leave okay okay okay
don't be real if you smile all right
hold on that really [ __ ] broken no no
all right hold on
give me a sort of [ __ ] god dude
i will leave chinchin
you can't make a joke that's his name
all right but it's not his name yeah
what's your name again
all right give me a second don't you
give me a second all right i just wasn't
ready for that i understand i'm gonna
say it again and if and if you smile i'm
gonna leave welcome all right hold on we
can't threaten or smile all right
just
hold on no because then you're gonna
laugh don't laugh
get serious please open up here
when i was
you ready
don't cover your mouth though either hey
you can't cover your mouth
the thing is that i you know i'm telling
you something that's like a
it's i'm vulnerable and i'm expressing
i'm trying to a truth to you hey dude
you gotta get serious and if you cover
your mouth i just feel like you're
laughing nope let's do it all right so
when i was nine i was brutally molested
by
a guy
you can't say brutal boy because that's
a curveball
because don't say and look at chin now
adjectives there
so when i was nine years old um
every day for a
summer can't throw [ __ ] in there why
because you [ __ ]
i can't
why can't i every day
oh she's true i'm going to hello
i'm just adding
i'm
every day you couldn't avoid them
because